What if the most deadly animal on the planet
could be wiped out?
Hey!
This is Carin for DNews with an amazing scientific
breakthrough that has the potential to save
millions of lives.
Malaria kills almost 630K people per year,
mainly in sub-saharan Africa, making anopheles
mosquitoes the deadliest animal on the planet.
It's actually only the females that spread
the disease to humans because they require
a blood meal to nourish their developing eggs.
Male mosquitoes get by on nectar or other
sugary substances and are therefore not a
threat to humans.
Scientists have hypothesized for decades that
creation of an extreme male-biased sex ratio
in natural mosquito populations could lead
to their demise.
However, such a feat hasn't been physiologically
possible - until now.
Researchers have just announced that a specific
endonuclease (or enzyme) has been created
to destroy the x chromosome of male mosquitoes.
This means that males will only ever pass
on a Y chromosome to their progeny, making
them all male.
Female mosquitoes (as with female humans)
only ever pass on an X chromosome to their
offspring, so it's actually the type of sperm
that determines the sex of the resulting babies.
The endonuclease (I-Ppol) recognizes a specific
set of repeating sequences on the X chromosome
of the males, and shreds the DNA during the
process of spermatogenesis.
This means that the only viable sperm produced
by the infected mosquitoes contain a Y chromosome.
Previous trials with this same enzyme were
unsuccessful because it remained active in
the fertilized zygote long enough to also
shred the X chromosome contributed by the
mother, killing all the embryos.
By destabilizing the endonuclease so that
it becomes inactive after sperm generation,
scientists have allowed for the production
of healthy, fertile, ALL male populations
to thrive.
This is a massive feat in both structure-based
protein engineering and molecular genetics.
Experimental mosquito populations infected
with the endonuclease are up to 95% male.
In research trials, these genetically modified
mosquitoes were introduced into five separate
cages filled with normal anopheles populations.
In four of the five cages, the entire population
was wiped out due to a lack of females.
The effects of the endonuclease on spermatogenesis
remain active in the male mosquitoes for at
least 4 generations after introduction, which
means that affected males continue to produce
mostly male offspring.
This makes the technique 'self sustaining',
inexpensive, and extremely effective.
So far, research has only taken place in the
lab.
Future steps will be to introduce genetically
modified males into natural populations in
order to look at larger scale effects.
Malaria is one of the largest threats to humans
worldwide.
The WHO estimates that over 3.4 billion people
are at risk for the disease each year (that's
HALF of the worlds' population!!), and over
600K will die.
So this is a huge development in the fields
of science and medicine.
What do you think?
Are humans playing with fire by introducing
genetically modified organisms into the natural
world or would the health benefits be worth
it?
Leave your comments below and subscribe here
for more DNews